الصوره دائما يعني ابلغ من الكلام وابلغ
من الشرح انت هنا لا تستمع الا الى اصوات
سيارات الاسعاف طبعا هنالك المئات من
سيارات الاسعاف التي تنقل للاسف جثامين
القتلى التي يتم يعني اخراجها من تحت
الانقاذ الدمار هائل في كل مكان هذه
المدينه تعتبر المدينه الاكثر دمارا من
المدن التي تضررت بدراء هذا الزلزال انا
ساسير بالكاميرا سالتفت انا والزميل
المصور يعني حتى تشاهد الكاميرا كيف يبدو
الدمار في كل مكان في هذه المدينه نحن وسط
انطاكيا عاصمه ولايه هاتاي الاكثر دمارا
هنالك طبعا عشرات بل المئات من المباني
التي حتى هذه اللحظه لم يتم اخراج
العالقين فيها سواء يعني كانوا على قيد
الحياه او او اموات للاسف يعني هنالك
جثامين تخرج تباعا من هذه المباني التي
يتم تتم فيها اعمال
الانقاذ وا اسير ايضا خالد بالكاميرا حتى
تشاهد كميه الدمار الهائل طبعا هنالك
مستشفى في نفس الشارع الذي انا اتواجد فيه
تدمرت بالكامل على تقريبا عشره او ثمان
كيلو ثمان كيلو مترات على بعد ثمانيه كيلو
مترات من هنا كانت تعمل لمستشفى خاص كانت
تعمل وهي مدمره بالكامل هنالك استنفار
كبير هذا المبنى مثلا الذي يظهر امامك في
الصوره قبل قليل كانوا استخرجوا منه جثث
للسيدات يعني للاسف فارقوا الحياه تحت
الانقاض من جراء هذا الانهيار هنالك اعداد
كبيره جدا من المباني المنهاره جزئيا
وبالتالي هنالك خشيه حقيقيه من الهزات
الارتداديه التي تحدث اليوم صباحا ونحن
يعني بيتنا هذه الليله في السياره والجميع
هنا يعني رات في سيارتهم لانه تعرف هنالك
خوف اساسا من المبيت داخل المباني شعرنا
بشكل كبير جدا بالهزه التي حدثت اليوم
صباحا في
في انطاكيا وسط مدينه هاتاي طبعا هنالك
طائرات مروحيه عسكريه تحلق على مستويات
منخفضه هنا في المدينه تنقل على ما يبدو
مساعدات على الجانب الاخر ايضا من حيث اقف
هنالك دمار هائل في المباني هنالك طبعا
فرق متطوعين تاتي تباعا واليات تاتي تباعا
كنت يعني احنا وصلناها ليله امس فجرا كنت
ايضا شرحت بان الناس هنا كانت تشتكي بانه
عمليات الانقاذ تاخرت قليلا على هاتاي
وهنالك من يبرر بانه البلاد كلها في صدمه
كبيره من جراء ما حدث وكميه الدمار هائل
جدا وبالتالي هم في يعني هنالك عدم قدره
على تلبيه جميع المباني المنهاره التي
يتواجد فيها
تحت الانقاض اشخاص لا زالوا حتى هذه
اللحظه على كما تعلم يعني اعداد القتلى
للاسف ترتفع مع كل ساعه لانه عمليات البحث
هذه الطائره عسكريه مثلا تحلق على مستوى
منخفض فوق مدينه هاتاي لنا تنقل مساعدات
ام جرحى مثلا لانه لانه يتم نقل الجرحى من
هذه المدينه الى مستشفيات مثلا مدينه اضنه
الاقل تضررا من هاتاي يمكن القول بانه هذه
المدينه خالد منكوبه بالكامل فعلا يعني
اينما اينما نظرت انت هنالك مباني مدمره
بشكل كامل وهنالك طبعا يعني حاله شهاده
اشخاص كانوا للاسف تبلغوا بان
يعني خفارقوا الحياه تحت الانقاذ هناك
حالات يعني انهيار وحزن شديد وبكاء طبعا
وهذا طبيعي ولكن السؤال الاكبر كم تبقى من
الاشخاص خالد تحت الانقاض يعني نحن نعلم
ارقام القتلى نعلم ارقام الجرحى ولكن
السؤال الذي يصعب تنبؤ باجابته او حتى هذه
اللحظه كم عدد الاشخاص الذين في عموم
تركيا لا يزال تحت الانقاض وكم يستغرق
تستغرق عمليات البحث ورفع الانقاض من وقت
ولكن ربما قرار حاله طوارئ الذي تحدثت عنه
لمده ثلاثه اشهر يجيب على هذا السؤال بان
هذه العمليات ربما تحتاج الى وقت وقت كبير
كما تعلم ايضا نحن انهينا يومين مع فجر
هذا اليوم ودخلنا في اليوم الثالث وهنالك
حاله من الاستياء بانه وخوف كبير على من
كان على قيد الحياه بانه الوقت ليس في
صالحه وهذا هذه الحرب مع الوقت بلا فرق
الانقاذ الجميع هنا طبعا الجيش يشارك
الامن يشارك الدفاع المدني متطوعين من
عموم المناطق حتى يعني اشخاص سوريين كانوا
يقيمين هنا كلهم تطوعوا للبحث تحت الانقاض